guys I'm so excited to be here I have
two degrees in clarinet so that's why I
do comedy
clarinet never came in handy for
anything unless maybe like you're
driving and then you hit a deer and you
don't have a crowbar in your trunk to
put it out of its misery yeah
yeah last time I hit a deer I had my
clarinet with me and I only got through
like two songs and he was out that's how
good I am well I love doing shows in LA
I was sick of people other places
appreciate me for what's on the inside
[Applause]
I know I I'm grabbin northern Wisconsin
you know I gotta wear a lot of makeup
just to look plain I don't fit in and
then there's always some yoga hoodlum
here who they're giving me bad Zen
advice like Oh Mary you gotta live in
the now living in what am i a superhero
now that's like you don't even know in
the now is till a little bit after than
now like sometimes several days go by
before I realize it's now is the worst
applause break ever on this show
[Applause]
how tall drink of water over there huh
Andy Richter all right uh San Francisco
people oh I'm from the Bay Area so I
always say oh yeah you from Green Bay
there's so many fans I mean that's kind
of pretentious just to claim to very
vague geographical features for yourself
they an area people when people ask me
where I'm from I don't say inland and
expect
yeah sometimes it will say oh I'm from
the woods but I'm rarely snooty about it
my mom still lives in the woods she's
had two heart attacks up there and
private already and she Shakira Dom was
aspirin and hot brandy brandy it's a
natural remedy like I want color
alcoholic I'd call her alcohol istic
okay some people don't believe in
Western medicine some people don't even
like antidepressants but for a while my
mom was taking them and I felt great
[Applause]
oh here just phone autos pregnant
yeah what with rage hi I am storing up
anger and the lady who I pay to listen
to me taxes actually the lady who the
government pays to listen to me
somebody got a grant for being unstable
it's easy anybody can do it
things could be worse
remember that I one time I knew this gal
who was born with her some and her index
finger stuck together just like that
yeah like everything's okay not really
yeah her hand was frozen the thumbs up
position so this poor girl could never
have a bad day she was miserable
[Laughter]
sometimes I have more fun in my head
then the people well let me leave you on
some parting advice if I could don't
ever let people walk on you okay I got
it I got a new model I am NOT the victim
you want to try it I am the killer
[Applause]
you